nous allons être un bon lion
je veux dire je peux le voir
je peux voir ton avenir quand je ferme les
yeux  mesdames je peux le sentir
venir donne moi une petite promenade
laisse moi t'entendre brut oh mec j'essaie de
concentrer ton petit lion rugissant
tu me dois de l'argent que tu n'as pas
je t'offre une opportunité sans prise
royale
400k  à cette adresse
à cette heure la semaine prochaine et le lion reste sur
le coton
tu ne me vois pas comme un boxeur pour moi qu'est
-ce que tu veux dire
tu n'as pas cette chose quelle chose
cette chose
[Musique]
je ne me promène pas  aller comme ça aux
gens
je pourrais te tuer mais je n'obtiens jamais de
retour sur mon investissement
nous avons une option
nous nous battons
[Musique]
tu m'utilises à partir de ce que je suis bon
et tout le monde le sait
pour toi
je sais ce que tu essaies de faire
tu ne sais pas pourquoi je fais ce que je fais
on ne va pas te perdre
[Musique]